[Music]
and get a job news submitted by Korean
barbecue
influencer couple got dragged after
asking fans for money for a ridiculous
international trip oh my lord or one
another one asking fans for money yes
yeah so this couple here they're from
Germany Shane yeah they run this account
called another beautiful day official
and they are asking for about ten
thousand euros are a little over eleven
thousand dollars and they've even
created a GoFundMe page they have about
forty seven thousand followers on
Instagram by the way dude that's a lot
of money we're to try to go so Oh so the
thing is they want to do a biking trip
where they bike by themselves Germany to
Africa not a specific country
it just says Africa what does he look
like that I mean like a gangster like he
looks like you're some kind of thirty or
something he treated his face as a Word
document he looks like the bad guy in a
movie wait that's right yes you'll not
see what is he I don't know but they all
come as Nexus Fred
it says freedom yeah so even one of them
says like looking look nice irritated
what do they want the money fluoride to
go on the trip
yeah girl [ __ ] your Adsense what are
they doing like do they understand that
traveling is a [ __ ] luxury not a
necessity yeah yeah but they're asking
for money they're not demanding money
people have people have the ability not
to participate yes but the audacity to
even like put it out there into the
universe to say I want to live a life of
luxury that I obviously cannot afford
but maybe you can afford people who
would probably have it worse than we do
yeah
give me money so I can go from Germany
tap yeah but they'd choose to have it
work yeah at least try to spin it for
the audience like but if you give me the
money if I go to Germany then you can
watch my vlogs yeah they're saying like
you know oh my god like this [ __ ] this
bull said and I don't hate it as much if
they're giving you something that's not
even shadier though are you trying to
cover it in a sugarcoat it
what does it sound like cuz it cuz it
sounds like we're gonna give we're gonna
do vlogs and just pay us money so that
we can do our vlogs are not like it's
one thing to like have a what is it
called like a GoFundMe or something for
like a movie or a short film or
something okay that got ran over about
carding extra money to fix it down yeah
I think because lifestyle bloggers you
expect them to be that way and you're
looking at their real life you know you
know yeah it's not like hey I'm actually
like broke but like fun my fake
lavishness yeah just so you guys know
they're not vloggers they're just on
Instagram Oh what the [ __ ] so there is
no video I thought they were travel
think travel bloggers notice of their
travel models because they the model so
what could they be like another decent
model that just has sex for money well
they just get a green screen and they
could put any city in the behind them
that's truly right they don't need to be
there that's more decency
their names are Kat and Elena who's who
hope he's Elena oh so he's cat boy well
he has good neck flexibility yeah so the
rating things a sad boy being a fury
ating part of this story of life oh we
haven't gotten to that yet
what's even so he says that his mother
works two jobs to pay for their vacation
oh my lord
he's using that as a sympathy card but
he just showed how much of a scumbag
it's momma chooses to
work two jobs just like yeah why are we
gonna hide it
my mom pays for trips I like that more
than a faker though like cuz there's
speakers out there that get their
parents paying for the lavish apartment
and they're these like lifestyle vlogger
like yeah don't [ __ ] give up on your
dreams and [ __ ] in this guy's like my
mom bought it for me well I get that but
I think I can't respect him in a I know
what you're getting at but I respect him
because he's he's thinking it's okay so
he hasn't grown up and he's just like
rubbing it he loves me yeah and it's
like you're [ __ ] delusional a little
boy yeah yeah I wish that on top of his
gigantic freedom tattoo that's on his
neck it said my mom pays for my and now
because my mom bought this one and this
one that's out tacky if anything
shouldn't he maybe like be like oh I
want to raise money and take my mom
exactly she needs a break people are
saying so he posted this on Facebook and
someone screenshot at it and then he
deleted it and then they posted it on
their GoFundMe page and they said like
people who saw this said where can we
donate to have your mom go on over here
someone will tell us to get jobs like
everyone else and stop begging but when
you have the impact we do on others live
getting a job is not an option
what inspiration and impact do they have
so done these are the people who say
[ __ ] like when you are poor you choose
to be poor you choose that for yourself
like these are those people he's like
because you don't have the right
positive mindset yes to get you to where
I'm at no [ __ ] people just
follow you because you look [ __ ]
mm-hmm the other part the other couple
isn't it he said we could model and make
fast money but we don't want to
advertise consumerism a normal job at
this point would be detrimental to
motors brand even the words he uses are
[ __ ] annoying like we're gonna say
detrimental like that like like he's
like that gets big voice [ __ ]
my own I would fund for their bike ride
trip if they're gonna go from Europe
toward Isis territory and then enjoy
fund that [ __ ] alright check for $10,000
round so yeah he continues he says we
could live a lavish lifestyle and only
show that like most people on social
media do we choose not to we have seen
how people are around us when we have
money and what we don't
some people are quick to judge and speak
at this very moment we don't have very
much we are accepting money from my
mother and also donations but we don't
hide that and not so by the way he's
this caption was with this photo right
where'd it go you refuses to work so is
this photo I initially showed you and
then some more photos of the girlfriend
sipping wine and doing yoga at like this
really fancy hotel
that's like photo the photos that they
chose because my mom gave this to me
that photo they need text on it says
thank my arm I wonder if they're actual
rich kids or I will know the master job
it just blows my mind that this exists
right and there also he was also saying
like you know my mom she's working two
jobs but she doesn't have much for her
herself but she funds my trip but Arthur
aren't there moms out there that are
like super giving and like they just
they just love babying the [ __ ] out of
their little boy and like paying for
everything and not letting them really
grow like yeah like so that so they have
the what do you call it the manchild
syndrome where they they're like always
a mama's boy and they can't leave the
house and all that stuff and so that's
kind of that right oh yeah this is what
gives Millennials bad names man this is
this is the kind of [ __ ] that everyone
goes this is a millennial now and it's
typical melena behavior that's not all
of them bro
yeah cuz then you do have the other
Millennials who are successful and on
their own at sixteen and already making
millions and [ __ ] yeah
Millennials if they're 16 they're like
early 20s or something yeah or they're
under mountains of student debt and
they're working their ass off you're
still working the ass off yeah they know
like some stuff they can take great
trips for like 250 dollars around the
world yeah shut up and go damn and I
think there's a lot of pressure though
for people to live it up because
everyone is kind of living it up on
Instagram right so like some people be
like I look so fun everyone's in Japan
in pairs and all these things you know I
want to go there one day and in when you
do it you want to do it like them you
want to save up and you want to stay at
the Ritz you want to go and do like
whole thing yeah I think a lot of people
are influenced by that that is yeah cuz
it just looks so fun I need just my
anybody you follow it on your feet if
people are like did I can Santorini and
this other blue water this one then you
kind of want to do all these things to
kind of live up and you want I want my
feet to look like this especially if you
can't afford it I think that's the thing
is that it's such a dream right like so
for example like you know like I had a
dream car and it was a something that I
wanted it was like $40,000 and I was
like oh one day I'll have it but once
you make more than that it's like I
don't care yeah yeah but a lot of people
don't can't afford it that's why they
dream about and they follow these guys
because they kind of like live through
their lifestyle you know a couple years
ago a bunch of instagramers at the same
time they all went to Greece and it was
one of those things went through
repetition and my feed and seeing it oh
yeah I was like holy [ __ ] I want to go
to Greece now and I never even had that
thought before if it wasn't one of my
top ten places no offense degrees you're
a bankrupt culture I'm kidding no but
that's what I kept thinking about Greece
right I don't but it's beautiful though
no it's really lovely I didn't know me
and Geo wanna go it's not for you before
that and then I saw everyone there I'm
like kind of want to go anymore all
depleted out we played it out Wow how
about you do you like travelling games I
do like traveling it's a fair place
Wyoming Hawaii is the my favorite so far
yaa but the Division one bra relaxing
beautiful views just like very chill all
right - yeah so you get influenced by
other people it's travels no like if I
see something that's really cool I get
more
are influenced by what the food looks
like oh then the places you get
influenced by anything on Instagram like
others like either clothes that I see on
like ancient aliens that maybe it's like
another dimension or something or like
those stones that big-ass people just
left it in I don't really care but I
think because I am an influencer or
whatever yeah I can't really affect me
because I I know half the time they're
getting paid to say it it's just like
it's different you know yeah do you guys
feel like social media leads to this
type of entitlement and Mike Norris yes
clearly I think this type of people
exist even without social media cuz I've
known like rich ass friends that
influenza yeah they just feel like their
parents owe them something already and
they their parents should be paying for
everything that they want to do and it's
the projection [ __ ] right like like like
people are my parents dealing with this
where they felt like their neighbors had
just bought a car and then we always
hang out with those people said they
wanted to buy a new car and it's like
that same kind of thing because you're
right exactly
and that has that's what social media is
now I feel like it's keeping up with the
Joneses and the Joneses are constantly
in your feet and in your life every and
I think it's on steroids
hell yeah cuz before you only had your
block to compare it to and you're
relatively around the same like status
but now you know what billionaires live
like exactly that's different I even see
them it's like I'll post a picture of
tiger and like all of a sudden it got
baby fever like crazy and they go oh I'd
never wanted a baby I want a baby so bad
we're kaneki damn that's crazy
we hung out with you guys the other day
and I was playing with Tiger that's
actually hanging up but brother I am
like I go home and like like like I hear
the door closed behind me and then I'll
kick he's like you're home and I'm like
oh no I got a [ __ ] okay
you know I mean like like I like I'll be
in my in bed and I'm like okay I think
Nikki's downstairs and then I move a
little bit because I just woke up and
then Nikki's like Nikki look up here's
all my legend sex song because she wants
to have a kid so bad right now it's very
cute asked if she was really good with
Micah like while we were all talking
about my cat thank you you know why cuz
her dad was too busy I was too busy no
cats in the cradle